Human beings are the only animals
capable of contemplating
their own mortality,
and they've been doing that
for thousands of years.
And yet somehow, in the very recent past,
we have lost the practical wisdom
of what happens as people die.
I think that that's a problem.
And if you agree with me
that it is a problem,
then we have to work out
what we're going to do about it.
When she was in her mid-20s, in the 1920s,
my grandmother was already deeply familiar
with the sequence of events
that happened to a human person
as they were coming
to the end of their life.
And that’s because, as a woman --
and it was usually women’s work --
she was doing what women
had done for centuries,
looking after people
at the very end of their lives,
in their own beds, in their own homes,
supported by their own people,
because hospital had nothing to offer,
once a person was so sick
that their death was imminent.
And yet, when I reached my mid-twenties,
in the 1980s,
I had none of her wisdom and understanding
and knowledge of dying,
and that was even though I'd just finished
five years of medical school.
As a newly qualified doctor,
I'd spent five years being trained
to stop people from dying.
And actually, if a death happened,
it was a thing that was seen
as a medical disaster.
It was a thing that was embarrassing,
it was a thing of which we do not speak.
Why the difference,
and why within just a couple
of generations?
Think about what happened to medicine
over the course of the 20th century.
It was not worth going to hospital
when you were dying
in the 1920s.
But by the 1960s, '70s, '80s and onwards,
think of the fantastic progress
that had been made
so that people who were so sick
that they might die,
of course we took them to hospital,
because there were antibiotics,
there were really clever anesthetics
that allowed surgeons
to spend a long time unpicking things
during operations.
There were new and very sophisticated
treatments for cancers,
for heart failure, for kidney failure.
There were intensive care units,
there was transplantation of organs,
some of that pioneered in this very city.
Medical progress was astonishing,
taking dying people to hospital
very often saved their lives,
and that is fantastic.
And yet ...
By taking dying people out of home
and putting them in hospital,
we changed our understanding
of the process.
We lost our ownership of the process
and we gave it to healthcare ...
And we forgot what dying looked like.
So, having been qualified
for just over four years,
I find myself in a new job.
Having originally intended
a career in cancer medicine,
I’d spent the last four years
choosing to train
in the places where the most
sick people were.
And then I realized that actually,
what was really interesting to me
was the detective journey
of symptom management
and the emotional integration
of feeling well enough
to live a little bit
during the very end of life,
and I went to work in a hospice.
But I'd been working
in a big teaching hospital,
I'd learned a lot of medicine,
I'd seen a lot of dying.
We had a patient in the hospice.
She was a memorable woman
for many reasons.
She had been a member
of the French Resistance
during the Second World War.
She'd married a British airman,
she'd come to live in England.
She'd never lost her French accent.
She had a cloud of glorious white hair,
like a halo.
She had piercing brown eyes,
the kind of gaze that you feel
a person can see your soul.
She was self-contained,
she was a little bit aloof.
In fact, she was a little bit scary.
(Laughter)
One day, she told the nurse
who was looking after her
that she was terrified of dying in agony,
because if she were to die in agony,
she might despair in God.
And if she were to despair in God,
as a French Roman Catholic,
her belief was that that
would be a mortal sin,
so she would not be able to go to heaven,
and heaven was the place she knew
her husband was waiting for her.
This was a profound existential distress.
And my boss said, "We need to go
and talk to her, and you should come,
you'll find this interesting."
I was 26.
Do you remember 26?
It's the last age when you know
that you know everything.
(Laughter)
So I went along,
wondering what I might learn,
because I thought
I was quite good at pain control.
That conversation ...
changed my life.
It changed my career.
And it's brought me here.
Sitting on her bed,
with me on a little footstool
so I can see him and her,
and the nurse sitting on the chair,
he said to her,
"I'm concerned that you've got worries
about what might happen as you're dying."
And she said yes.
She knew him well, she trusted him.
And he said, "I'm sorry to hear that,
and I wondered whether it might help you
if I described to you what usually happens
as a person is dying."
And I'm sitting on the stool
of all knowledge, thinking,
"You can't tell her that."
(Laughter)
Because I’ve seen lots of dying,
and I know they’re all different.
And she said, "Yes, please."
And he said, "I'll describe
what we usually see,
and if it gets too much, you tell me.
Promise, I'll stop.
The thing that's really
interesting, Sabine,
is that as people are dying,
it doesn't really matter
what the illness is they're dying from.
The pattern of events is very similar.
We see people becoming
more and more tired.
It's harder and harder for them
to find the energy to do things.
In fact, they recharge their energy
not so much by eating and drinking,
but by sleeping.
And as time goes by,
what we see is that people sleep more
and they're awake less.
And if they want to do
something important,
they should take a snooze before it."
She nodded, and she got hold of his hand.
"As time goes by," he said,
"we see people are asleep for longer,
they're awake for shorter,
and something interesting
we notice that they don’t is,
maybe it's medicine time,
or there's a visitor,
we need to waken them ...
For a period, we can't waken them.
They're not just asleep,
they're actually unconscious.
And when they waken,
they tell us they've had a lovely sleep.
It turns out that human beings
don't recognize
when we become unconscious.
And so at the very end of somebody's life,
they're not just asleep,
they're actually deeply unconscious.
And when the brain is unconscious,
the only part of it that's still working
is the part that's working
their breathing."
By now, she is sitting right up in bed.
She's got hold of one of his hands,
and she's stroking it.
She's nodding at everything he says.
And in the meanwhile,
I’m sitting on my stool,
horrified that he seems to be describing
dying to a dying person.
And that feels, to me,
to be really not very OK.
But she is mesmerized.
"By the time the brain
is deeply unconscious,"
he's saying to her now,
"the only bit that's still working
is the bit that drives the breathing.
And so breathing cycles
we don't normally see start to happen.
Reflex automatic breathing
cycles from very deep breaths
becoming shallower and shallower,
and then going back
to the beginning again,
cycles of fast breathing
that gradually become slower,
maybe with pauses,
and then back to the beginning again.
The person can't feel their throat.
They don't notice if they breathe out
through their voice box,
making a noise families might think
that they're sighing
or groaning, or uncomfortable.
We'll always check,
but it's part of this reflex breathing.
Saliva or mouth-cleaning fluid
won't irritate their throat,
it won't make them cough or swallow.
They just lie there
with a little pool of fluids,
sometimes in the back of their throat.
It's not in the way.
Air is moving in and out of their lungs,
and it bubbles through
that little film of fluid,
but families can mistake that
for drowning or choking.
So one of the things
that we'll do, Sabine,
if your nieces and nephews are here,
is we will make sure we explain to them
what is happening to you."
She's stroking his hands, she's nodding.
She is absolutely taking in
everything that he says.
And then he says -- and I think,
"Oh my goodness,
he's going to the last breath."
"And then, during, usually,
one of those phases of slow breathing,
there'll be a breath out ...
that just isn't followed
by another breath in.
There is nothing special
about the last breath.
It's so not like
on the television or in cinema.
There's no rush of pain at the end.
There's no sudden panic.
There's no feeling of fading away.
Sometimes, we who work
in palliative care,"
and I've subsequently
discovered this to be true,
"sometimes, we will walk into a room
where a family has been around a person
who is in the act of dying,
and we'll realize the person
has stopped breathing,
and the family hasn't noticed yet,
because the Hollywood finale
that they're waiting for hasn't happened."
She got hold of both of his hands.
She shook them in hers,
and then she pulled his hands
to her face and she kissed them.
And then, she closed her eyes,
she lay back on her pillows.
I just watched her relax,
and in her own inimitable and aloof way,
she told us that we were
no longer required.
(Laughter)
And my boss said to me, “Are you OK?”
And I said, “Yes.” (Voice breaking)
And I went to the kitchen
to blow my nose and dry my eyes,
and think about what just happened.
Two huge ideas exploding in my brain
at the same time.
One is "How have I never noticed that?"
That pattern that he has just explained,
I have seen hundreds of times.
But I was the most junior doctor.
It was my job to stop
the person dying, remember?
So I was so busy worrying
about this person's oxygen levels
and that person's pulse,
and this person's kidney function
that I didn't stand back and see
that there's a pattern going on here.
We can describe the process
of ordinary human dying,
and it's as much a process
as the process of giving birth is.
It has stages.
We can recognize them,
we can pace ourselves.
We can work out where we are in it.
But even more fascinating
was that realization
from watching Sabine's reaction,
that we can describe
ordinary dying to a dying person ...
and it shines the light
of understanding and information
into that dark place
where all their fears
and imagination were at play.
I've gone on in my career
in palliative care
to have that conversation
thousands of times, countless times.
I always offer to stop.
I've never been stopped.
But what happens at the end
is that relaxation,
that moment of, "Well, that isn't
what I was expecting,"
followed almost immediately
by "Can you tell my family that?"
“Can you tell my wife, my husband,
my kids, my parents?
That’s not what we’re expecting.”
And I think we can do that.
So losing the wisdom really matters.
And we can't leave it
to palliative care people,
or even medical people,
to reclaim that lost wisdom,
one family at a time.
This is a massive
social public health issue.
And I invite everybody
who's listening to step up.
The reason my grandmother
understood about dying
was that she'd seen it
alongside people who knew it,
who described to her,
as the process was happening,
what she was seeing,
so that she would understand
and not be afraid.
And it requires all of us who are mortals,
all of us who love other mortals,
to step up, to say, “Enough,
death is not a medical event,
it's a social event.
It's a deeply personal event.
And we can understand it,
we can describe it,
we can console each other.
We can accompany each other.
We can reclaim dying."
Thank you.
(Applause)